[Music]
where on a warplane in Wartime Sudan
from the Red Sea Coast to the capital
and just across the Nile Horton is on
fire
even as we're standing here you can hear
the popping sounds in the distance and
as you look back you see more smoke
start to billow out over the city and
this is meant to be a ceasefire period
but from where we're standing there
doesn't seem to be any ceasefire
this military base and the surrounding
territory was reclaimed from the rapid
support forces in the last two weeks
but the battles continue further south
and the scars of War remain
but the fighting isn't taking place in a
distant Battlefield it's in the places
people need the most
foreign he says that rapid support
forces snipers were in the buildings
behind this Pharmacy and at the front
and they ended up confronting each other
right here in the storefront
California bridge and its roundabout is
now secure within a five kilometer
radius but people are still suffering
I'm sure
after 30 minutes
in a nearby Military Hospital Ward
wounded soldiers recover from their
injuries
gunshot wounds and in the worst of cases
their degree burns
Khalifa Allah is only 22 years old it
was burnt in a car during the fighting
and is now healing at a steady but
painful pace is
thank you
Sudan's Army says the fighting started
after a surprise coup offensive by the
rapid support forces people slept on
Friday night and woke up to war on
Saturday morning is there anything that
could have been done to avoid this how
did it even get to that point
foreign
[Music]
these guys say they now feel secure
after the armed forces push the rapid
support forces out of their neighborhood
foreign
people are now turning to the Army for
protection
and the only normal life is in the
shadow of Tanks
Sky News